welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and d23 revealed the lineup of
marvel studios thunderbolts including
julia louis dreyfus as contessa
valentina like her day fontaine a val
david harper as alexis shustakov red
guardian hannah john cayman as eva star
ghost from ant-man and the wasp oh god
curlienko as antonia drakov taskmaster
from black widow wyatt russell as john
walker us agent for the fact of the
winter soldier florence pugh as healing
the bulova and sebastian stan as bucky
barnes and depending how much you loved
black widow and the falcon of the winter
soldier this is either a rogue super
soldier dream team or a bit of a mixed
bag
but actually when you go through each of
these thunderbolts backgrounds one by
one and look ahead what crises they're
probably going to be facing it's very
possible the plot of this thunderbolts
film could tie in with things like the
intelligentsia doctor doom white vision
and more i'm gonna explain how and why i
am so excited for this thunderbolts
movie so in the comics the thunderbolts
is really a rotating lineup of
anti-heroes taking less noble missions
that would be considered a bit of a
disgrace for the avengers or simply
illegal according to the us government
and world governments the first
thunderbolts was formed by baron zemo
using the identity of citizen v
pretending to use this thunderbolts team
as a kind of replacement for the
avengers but actually intending to use
it for more immoral objectives until the
rest of the team nobly turns on zemo
from therefore the thunderbolts lineup
was arguably best defined by whoever led
it in that particular era and whatever
societal context necessitated that
thunderbolt's existence for example
green goblin leads the thunderbolts
during the civil war storyline luke cage
leads the thunderbolts for a while
taskmaster tony masters leads it during
the king and black storyline us agent
john walker leads it during devil's
reign when wilson fisk is the mayor but
generally whenever i think of the
thunderbolt zemo and john walker are
part of the mix at least but still
there's no one definitive lineup of who
the thunderbolts are in the marvel
comics so marvel studios is really free
to just plug in any anti-hero to serve
whatever narrative need they want to
tell so when we look at the mcu movies
and shows val put this thunderbolts
lineup together she's really the nick
fury but really amanda waller style
manager of this crew and of this lineup
the team captains seem to be bucky
barnes and elena bolova with the other
members of the team red guardian john
walker ghost and taskmaster playing
crucial supportive functions on this
mission remember we first met val in
episode 5 of the falcon the winter
soldier recruiting john walker and she
implied she came from a more shadowy
branch of the government and was
definitely more supportive of walker's
murderous actions with cap shield but
after that shield was taken from walker
she suited him up as u.s agent but
originally we were going to meet val in
black widow before that movie was
delayed in that post-credits scene where
she recruited elaine bolova at natasha's
grave sending her to kill clint barton
suggesting that val and thus her mission
with the thunderbolts is to truly
replace the avengers for the group that
she can more directly control and clint
barton is one of the few remaining
avengers that would be on her kill list
in the hawkeye series the elena does try
to kill clint but clint and kay bishop
changed her mind and the elena basically
forgives clint and they part ways and
reminder we last saw red guardian at the
end of the black widow film that was set
in 2016. this was in the debris field of
the red room floating base and he
departed with melina elena and the other
black widow agents along with a wounded
antonia dracov taskmaster that movie
whom natasha had cleared her of her
brainwashing with that antidote mist
reminder the big twist of that movie was
that drakov's daughter that loki
mentions in the 2012 avengers was the
daughter of general drakov and natasha
thought she had incinerated both father
and daughter in a targeted explosion but
both survived now bucky barnes we last
saw of course in the falcon the winter
soldier finally forgiven himself of his
dark past as the winter soldier assassin
and joining sam wilson captain america
in the defeat of the flag smashers but
ghost remains this team's one super
abled wild card her power is different
from everyone else we last saw her in
ant-man and the wasp trying to steal
hank pym's quantum technology in order
to cure herself of her quantum
entanglement that causes her to
chaotically phase shift this is until
janet van dyne returns to the quantum
realm and offers to cure her but ghost
ends that movie stumbling off with bill
foster in the streets of san francisco
while scott lang rushes home to trick
jimmy woo into thinking you never left
now this bucky elena-led team indicates
that their mission might be less of an
avengers level world-ending threat but
rather something a bit more covert like
a heist or an assassination an
extraction a kind of rescue operation
maybe it's some kind of kamikaze mission
that simply destroys a target so that
one of val's rivals won't have a weapon
that she won't have and this could
explain why it's so important to have
ava star ghost on this team and ant-man
the wasp we learned how ava as a kid got
caught in a blast of quantum energy that
supposedly killed her father elias starr
but leaving his daughter's body quantum
entangled that allows her to face shift
through matter now that movie never
fully addressed this but in the comics
elias starr becomes the marvel villain
egghead who is a founding member of the
intelligentsia alongside the leader haha
now you can see how it's becoming a bit
clearer what mission this thunderbolts
team might have been assembled to
complete now there are times when i'm up
so late that it cycles back to early and
i just have a hard time sleeping with
rosie finger dawn creeping into my
bedroom it used to be the case that when
that would happen i would grab a blue
blocks blackout sleep mask but now blue
blocks has become bond charge so i grab
a bond charge sleep mask instead i know
it sounds weird to say i'm bad at
sleeping but i am i don't know maybe i
have thin eyelids or something but if
i'm using bon charge's sleep mask that
doesn't matter it blocks out 100 of
incoming light and it's very soft and
has adjustable eye cups and an
adjustable strap for the perfect fit it
works for people sleeping on their belly
side and on their back it is super
comfortable and i can confirm that i can
see absolutely nothing if you're making
silly faces at me i wouldn't know i'm
just gonna take a quick nap right now in
a pack bond charge ships worldwide and
have other great products like low blue
light bulbs red light therapy devices
and blue light glasses go to
bondcharge.com new rockstars and use
coupon code new rockstars to save 20
that's
b-o-n-c-h-a-r-g-e dot com slash new
rockstars and use the coupon code new
rockstars to save 20
because tim blake nelson has been
confirmed to return to the mcu as the
leader from the 2008 hulk film and he's
going to show up in captain america 4
new world order this is the mcu title
coming directly before the thunderbolts
in the summer of 2024. in fact we might
even see the leader cameo as soon as
she-hulk considering the wrecking crew
was introduced and they have some
mysterious boss who is trying to acquire
she-hulk's blood and one of those
thieves trying to steal her blood might
be jen's creepy date todd who is
originally credited as hulk todd in an
early press screener and this guy
inquired whether vibranium could pierce
hulk's skin as if someone might have a
vibranium needle to extract some of her
blood keep an eye on todd and all this
mystery kind of reminds us of the
ant-man and the wasp mystery that we
were left with who was sonny burch's
mysterious buyer who was the one funding
his attempts to acquire the quantum tech
i think the shadowy threat behind all of
these is the intelligentsia a brainy
villain group that in the comics
includes the leader egghead and modoc
all these characters now either confirm
to or might come back to the mcu tim
blake nelson is the leader ava starr's
father as egghead and early footage of
quantomania that was shown at comic con
at d23 shows that modoc is for sure
coming back to the mcu i also would not
be surprised if the mcu might widen the
membership of the intelligentsia to
include victor von doom so the
intelligentsia in the mcu might possess
some super weapon that val either wants
for herself or wants to take out imagine
a piece of quantum tech maybe one of
tony stark's quantum navigators from
avengers endgame or a large supply of
vibranium in the form of a weaponized
synthezoid named white vision we don't
know where white vision went but i could
totally imagine white vision getting in
the hands of the intelligentsia and
programmed to be a serious threat so val
sends in the thunderbolts a team mostly
composed of super soldiers with similar
powers but there's an intentional reason
behind that because think about it if a
super soldier is captured and flipped oh
well it's not that huge of a risk to
lose a super soldier as opposed to
someone with hulk blood a weapon that
you definitely wouldn't want to risk
getting in your enemies hands but the
one wild card on this team is ghost a
phase shifter who not only could pretty
easily infiltrate any bass but could
also go toe-to-toe with a vision now
it's not totally clear if white vision
can face shift like vision can since
white vision doesn't have the mind stone
but either way ghosts would totally have
the advantage here i want to hear your
thoughts on this thunderbolt pitch and
follow me on tick tock instagram and
twitter eavos follow new rockstars
subscribe to rockstars for more analysis
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you